hello and welcome to see Oakland I am
Killian Carlo de Moura so I've got a 33
games 15 wins 15 losses three drawers
again so we had a goon felt symmetrical
here super solid opening okay three that
is not that B 3 III that doesn't look
very dangerous but still okay maybe he
really has special a3 and 95 stuff no
okay I don't don't mind that really I
don't think this is a big deal he's got
some weaknesses on the dark squares as
well Queenie 7 rook c8 looks okay so he
invites this with the tempo and okay
night before it's not really into that
much no particular reason to play this
now
ok this is to allow 97 at some moment I
wonder if a six looks is seven less
something I'm sure okay let's block this
for the moment and maybe 9 a-5
I have 94 94 takes pawn takes but what
about this isn't this also an option
Oh
Wow Wow then I cannot even play Queen to
e7
and don't tell me I'm lost here that
would be Oh actually I'm attacking f3 at
the end so maybe I still can play this
somehow kind of miraculously unnecessary
Knight a5 water then check that this is
crazy this is not that bad rook c8 rook
c8 queen a7 I've looxcie to this is
really crazy that this is still playable
for me okay Bishop c6 on you know I
guess
so that's better to be lucky than good
that's really applies to chess as well
completely overlooked naughty fun yeah
what to do with that Queen okay this one
yeah takes Queen takes is slightly
annoying for sure
so if i can move maybe a five here i'd
like to enter somehow here
I'm a fourth unfortunately not playable
may be here taking the pawn and
potentially queen bee to
hmm I do what but i can actually i can
actually do this and get be five now so
Queen B 5
yeah it should be okay
yeah it should be okay should be pretty
safe what is he going form time morning
yet another look may be coming there but
hoi go age five and echo droopy one
coming now that's equal I think it's not
much going on he looks more looks to be
more active but it's nothing serious
going on check draw a head check
29 seconds
check
check just a draw draw our third check
check check check check check check
check check check check draw aah chak
chak now I know I'm stumbling into this
error came back for offense on time
people are more interested in gaining
some cheap points than just having a
proper result yeah okay it's a draw all
the way but he won't on time or whatever
yeah I was an interesting game and it
was quite funny that that I will look
out look 94 and it was a really total
coincidence that that I'm not losing
them Jim now I can take only 3 with the
Queen maybe but I just saw that this is
a good move but I didn't see naughty boy
doll check yeah yeah and it's just a
total coincidence that i'm not losing a
piece or anything i try to clean before
engine wants to play rook c7 it's an
interesting move
now that looks more dangerous my queen
is offside this is the reason why why it
still has something m TM this is
probably not that much i'm here and i
think i just have equalised him yeah
check yeah this is this is just complete
row and it is it is a draw all the way
to the end check now maybe yet something
around here and okay I've got 20 seconds
he's got safety and check here there's
simply nothing but it's 13 seconds
against 26 so he wins the game yep what
can you do thanks for watching